le think tank terra nova a publié une
étude intitulée un bilan écologique du
quinquennat d'après la majorité
présidentielle les actions de l'état en
faveur de la cause environnementale
aurait atteint un niveau inédit depuis
l'accès au pouvoir des manuels macron
vrai selon l'auteur de cette note avec
quelques nuances importantes
les détracteurs d' emmanuel macron ainsi
qu tort lorsqu'il affirme que le
président de la république n'a rien fait
pour le climat ou la biodiversité et ce
dernier a clairement raison lorsqu'il
affirme que cette majorité est celle qui
en a fait le plus mais ce débat est tout
simplement celui d'une autre époque
l'enjeu explique marine bros l'auteur de
cette note n'est tout simplement pas de
savoir qui a fait quoi mais plutôt si
l'action mise en place est suffisante
pour faire face aux défis
environnementaux actuels dans ce
quinquennat des projets ont vu le jour
et il y a eu bien sûr aussi des ratés
mais plus globalement il manque une
réelle vision des futurs choix de
société certaines politiques innovantes
ont été lancées notamment sur les
questions liées à la biodiversité
mais je cite les moyens alloués à leur
mise en oeuvre qu'ils soient techniques
financiers humains ou de portage
politique ne semble pas toujours à la
hauteur des ambitions affichées sur le
front du climat l'étude de terra nova
déplore l'absence d'une réelle réflexion
systémique à propos de tous les sujets
liés à l'environnement il manque un vrai
portage les moyens une vision claire des
choix de société à faire au regard de la
transition écologique à conduire en 2021
selon terra nova 41% des français
placent l'écologie dans leurs trois
principaux sujets de préoccupation
à titre de comparaison en 2013 ils
étaient seulement 9% et pourtant malgré
cet intérêt de la population toujours
croissant pour l'écologie il semble
qu'elle soit la grande oubliée des
débats ainsi dans l'interview d'emmanuel
macron diffusée sur tf1 lci et intitulé
où va la france aucun mot sur la
politique énergétique du pays ou encore
la biodiversité un déni de démocratie a
dénoncé greenpeace à quelques mois de la
présidentielle l'auteur de l'étude
publiée par terra nova s'inquiète aussi
de l'absence de ces questions dans les
débats